oh my god I seem fun the diary of Jen
Kirkman podcast episode 227 coming at
you I think I have to adjust this chair
I think I'm too short I am in the brand
new all things comedy studio fantastic
oh my god is gorgeous and it's this
video this episode is gonna be available
on video so Erin we'll just I'll get
them the link closer to the date right
and and so you can find out how to watch
this episode by going to facebook.com
slash I seem fun podcast or following me
on Twitter at I seem fun podcast oh my
god this is I mean it is just beautiful
I cannot stop looking at myself in the
monitor because it's just you know those
good cameras that the good lighting
oh all right congratulations all things
comedy and let's get this [ __ ] going oh
my god I will I recorded an episode this
week already so I feel like I don't even
know what I'm gonna talk about Aaron
this beautiful camera work is
distracting me I'm going to take a
picture of myself on camera and this is
very annoying for everybody except for
me oh my God look at that okay alright
this is what we're gonna talk about the
other let's just do some business do
some business as you guys know not on
any official tour I will be back in
London on June 22nd for one show at the
Leicester Square Theatre it's a whole
thing I got to go to London for other
reasons I'm squeezing in a show
hopefully let in all the people that
could not get in too much a great time
great time acid reflux just come on up
into my voice he had all morning to do
it but you do it when I'm on mic so
everybody was I gonna say Oh London June
22nd Leicester Square Theatre come see
me and if you've seen me before yeah
it's not gonna be all new stuff I
apologize for that it's gonna be a
camping so
I don't know if you don't just want to
come see me again because it's fun to be
in the same room and why wouldn't it be
then come on down I do need a lot of
people there it's sort of a special
event for some people that are coming
out so I guess what I'm saying is help
girl out
go to iTunes write a review of the show
give it five stars the review is she's
always distracted okay and then all the
back episodes of this podcast exists on
soundcloud let's see I told you about
that I told you about this I will be at
the comedy attic in Bloomington Indiana
so very soon and Burlington Vermont at
the Vermont comedy club so get tickets
for that Jen Kirkman com click on tour
dates Indiana is May 10th through 12th
and Vermont is October 11th through 13th
I assume some kind of sporting event
will be happening in Vermont or
something I don't [ __ ] know last
every time I tour in the fall it's
always some mishegoss last year what was
I was in Houston and the Yankees are
playing the Houstons or whatever so that
was fun
all right it wasn't actually not fun in
case you didn't infer the sarcasm which
meant a lot less people came to my show
even people were like I know that into
sports but they say such a big moment I
get it I'm from Boston it's fun to watch
people beat the Yankees um all right so
I already recorded an episode this week
so I really don't know what I'm gonna
talk about but I might go to a listener
question and I also have a pretty cool
article that I just found about this guy
went to space and he has an identical
twin and after spending a year in space
his DNA no longer matches his identical
twins and I love [ __ ] like that I don't
really know what we're gonna do with
that information here at the I seem fun
podcast but maybe it would be something
that I don't know maybe you guys would
find that interesting for some reason so
here's what someone asked me now here's
an advice question and we'll just start
out with that I don't really know what
to tell you people you know
I'll give you an example so I can't tell
you what's going on at all and by the
time this airs I'm gonna know in two
hours the answer to a big career thing
and I shouldn't be talking about it
because I could get in trouble with the
thing itself and my other job so but
I'll just put it out there in the
podcast so I auditioned I went on an
audition I don't normally do that I'm
not I am an actress but I auditioning as
I say a lifestyle you must commit as
much time to it as you do anything else
the way I tore the many hours and days
and weeks and months I spend doing that
that's you know like auditioning is a
lifestyle you do it hours a day every
day what so and I've been in New York
writing on the marvelousness is Mazal
there's no auditioning in LA for pilot
season all of it I was home in LA my
agent called me said hey do you want to
go on this audition I said I sure do and
you know auditions are many multiple
levels and I auditioned and it went well
and they had me back to screen test
which I've never gone that far in the
process before and then today it is
being decided between me and another
woman for this role and if I get it I
will film a pilot I will probably be in
trouble with my job I don't know what's
gonna happen if I don't get it then I'm
not in trouble with anybody I'm just
disappointed so as I sit here I'm
waiting to hear that news so but after
so after the audition oh so I did this
thing where I was like it's at 9:00 a.m.
on the west side of LA I live in the
valley if anyone knows that is at least
without traffic a 40 minute drive with
Monday morning not Monday morning but
like rush-hour traffic it's about a
90-minute Drive and it's stressful the
whole time because your Waze keeps
blooping like go this way go that oh now
it's a 20 minutes more being at it so
it's a disaster so I was like I'm gonna
get a hotel I'm gonna really make sure
that I am as pampered and taken care of
as possible so I went and stayed in a
hotel like a fancy
Hotel in Beverly Hills near ich to where
I had to be in the morning so it would
only be a 10-minute drive and I went so
you know I use hotels comm they're not
an advertiser they should be and I had
so many credits from traveling all year
that basically I got this giant three
room suite completely paid for with only
about fifty bucks left over so I only
paid about fifty bucks to do this and
then in the morning I had a you know
those apps we get that glams go out or
whatever I had someone come and do my
hair makeup because when the hot lights
of television are on you you can look
pretty bad if you don't have Pro makeup
so I did that so you have to you have to
kind of take care of yourself like
nobody provides that for you you just
have to know and come prepared and it's
part of being a professional a
professional adult so and get to the
hotel
I always feel shady checking into a
hotel in the city I live in I feel like
I'm doing something dirty and especially
because I brought a lot of different
outfits so I did have like a full
carry-on suitcase which made me feel
weird because it was only one night but
then again if I only had a purse and
like a little tiny overnight bag I think
I would feel also weird like it just
makes you feel like a [ __ ] I guess is
what I'm saying I felt like a prostitute
who is coming although that's not what
prostitutes do right I don't think they
get their own suite and check-in
I think they wander the lobby and all
such kinds of things
by the way funny story maybe not that
funny I had a friend who worked in
events for a major Network and she would
come to town every year during the Emmys
and the Golden Globes and they would
always stay at the Four Seasons and so
she would be allowed to use the expense
account and I'd come have drinks with
her and Lobby have some dinner and there
would always be prostitutes I mean you
know like you're you're gorgeous
high-end prostitute you're Julia Roberts
after her makeover in a pretty young
thing and pretty women pretty woman
pretty women pretty woman
mash up pretty little women little women
but they're prostitutes anyway so the
the instilled instated stated put
together demanded came up with a law
that you had to pay like a twenty five
or fifty dollar cover charge just to get
into the Four Seasons lounge where you
could then purchase your drinks and food
and I guess that was supposed to deter
the prostitutes from coming in but I
believe they I think they lost some
clientele over that because I think the
point for a lot of men was to go and
find said ladies there so I don't really
know I don't really know what's going on
with the lobby of the Four Seasons
anymore because my friend doesn't have
that job so I don't know what's
happening but you know you try to keep
people oh and you ruin business you know
that's let the lobby be what it was a
place for men to meet their high end
prostitutes you don't let the ladies in
then what did the guys sittin there
drinking for to talk to each other to be
int to read a book at the bar no anyway
nobody was really questioning what I was
doing but I had my usual altercation at
check-in and I go why do I even why
don't I just say sure thanks why do I
need to talk back to people I'm so
stubborn about like being told what to
do and again I'm a former dancer
everybody ballerina up in here and all
they do is correct you and tell you what
to do and my teacher used to say part of
what makes you a good dancer which is
another way of saying because you're not
that good a dancer is that you take
correction you take correction really
well you listen and you do what we say
and so I'm and I love to learn and I'm
the first to admit I don't know anything
about many things and I like to be told
what to do like oh I and I always walk
into situations where if I don't know
what how things are done I'm happy to
ask but it's it's when I know what I'm
doing and I'm on a mission it's usually
involves traveling and people start
giving me advice I'm like I I'm going to
have an it's I'm just I'm not gonna
solve that one in this
lifetime it's just gonna be something
that annoys me but I'm checking in and
he's like what brings you to town and I
love that I I didn't have to make up
some lie cuz I'm on tour and I don't
have to talk about comedy I said
actually I live in the neighborhood I
had a free night I have a really early
morning and I know I didn't say Liv I
said I live in the city in the valley
and I have a really early meeting in the
morning and I wanted to be closer and
everyone understands I go out totally
the valley lovable so he's like well if
you're interested the restaurant and
starts going on go I'm actually not
already ate like I checked in at 6:00
I ate early not eating also trying to
like fit into my outfit the next day I'm
doing like a detox you know just like
just drinking lemon water and just
mutten myself just thin out overnight
for the cameras
I had haze like but if you change your
mind not gonna also how about this I see
there's a restaurant I've been to
restaurants I sort of get the deal of
how they work I'm sure you got some
thing about the restaurant you want to
tell me well maybe it's a happy hour
special chef menus tonight if I change
my mind
I'll pick up the phone in the room and
I'll say can I make a reservation tell
me about the restaurant there's nothing
I need to know it's not like but ma'am
there's a bomb in the restaurant we are
trying to tell every customer who checks
in please let us finish her sentence
like if someone's like I don't want to
hear it shut up people I'm a busy
businesswoman everybody just like in the
hallmark movies so then he says well if
you're interested in swimming I said I'm
not I didn't bring my bathing suit well
we have for sale I'm not buying I don't
want to swim there's no swimming I don't
care with the swimming I don't care
about swimming he goes well even if you
don't swim I mean there's always it's
like are you gonna die if you don't like
get one over on me if you don't say one
thing that I'm gonna go okay I am
interested in that like I already knew
what I was interested in I'm checking
into a hotel I had some work to do I was
gonna like take a bath there was a
beautiful bathtub in there and I was
gonna work on my lines and I was going
to go to bed at 10:00 and so I had
for hours I had a mall mapped out I
don't need your suggestions and he goes
but the rooftop has great views I go
yeah I've been to a event at this hotel
before I had dad I'd gone to a birthday
party at this hotel and he goes what the
views are beautiful I'm like no I get it
like again I live in LA I hike every day
mountains tall mountains I go to rooftop
things of in her 15 years I kind of know
what the view is and the view to be
honest is not great in the city you
can't see the stars I mean of course the
ones walking around outside I'm kidding
but you can't see the actual stars
because of the layers of whatever and it
was a rainy night so don't with the
views he kept going on the views and I
kept arguing going I'm not gonna go
upstairs I don't know why I guess my
point is I feel like well first of all
I'm just nuts I'm just [ __ ]
straight-up nuts and like that's one of
the things I'm nuts about it's like I
need you to know that you weren't
helpful I need you to know that what was
helpful was when you gave me my room and
when you let me get going I want to
teach them in a weird and this is a
total codependent issue I want to teach
them in a way hey every customer is
different like if someone says they are
local and they see views every day they
themselves live in a building that has
great views I don't need to keep pushing
it I just learned something by having an
interaction with that woman who for some
reason the interaction would have been
one second if I just let him say and
there's views up say uh-huh
but I just couldn't I need everyone to
know my specific thing at every moment I
don't know why it's an illness it's an
illness so anyway I stayed in the hotel
it was absolutely lovely and then after
the screen test that I did there's this
feeling of now it's out of my hands I
have no idea how I did there's like a
little bit of a wave of like self-hatred
and shame that comes in words like what
if I was terrible and
there's a little bit of like I kind of
feel excited and then there's a little
bit of your brain going don't get
excited you have disappointments this is
how this business is and then part of me
cuz you just can't think about it and
then that part of me goes what do you do
when you're trying not to think about
something now normally I have a schedule
it's tight you know I'll go on a hike
I'll do this I'll always have work to do
you could record a podcast you could do
this I couldn't decide what to do so I I
just ended up at the restaurant of that
hotel for a lunch and had a glass of
wine and some I don't know some kind of
egg thing and I thought I had a point
but I just realized that I think I've
talked about what I was gonna say
already but that's all I could think to
do like I was completely immobilized
most of yesterday waiting to find out if
I went to the next level and I did find
out at the end of the day yesterday they
went to the next level and then I was
exhausted as though I'd run a race and
so sometimes I just have to put myself
to bed at like 8 o'clock and go I need
to just go to bed I can't think anymore
about anything or wonder but I'm really
disappointed in my south carry us toward
a because there's so many things I could
have done to keep busy and instead I
decided I need to zone out and eat lunch
and have wine and then put myself in bed
that was I kind of wasted a day but it
brings me to I'm not at 30 mi 17 alright
so it brings me to my question I got
today oh there oh that was the point
sorry about the glass of one cheese i
order the wine the girl goes what's your
date of birth what year you born like it
was just a quick way to check that I was
of age I'm 43 I mean I don't look 21
that's not being ridiculous and I said a
1974 CH because oh my god you look
amazing good for you I'm like it's not
old don't I'm so sick of younger people
telling me I look amazing the its I'm
sorry you
look like crap cuz you're in the Sun and
I don't know what you're doing with
yourselves with the lip [ __ ] that you do
but the reason people my age may look
amazing is because we're not old
we still have estrogen we're not old
there are some people my age you look
like [ __ ] but they've looked like [ __ ]
forever
some people look like [ __ ] they don't
take care of themselves I don't mean
good-looking that subjective I'm talking
about whatever I don't know I've got
good genes my mom didn't have a lot of
wrinkles when she was my age she's 80
now and they're just coming in you know
I don't [ __ ] know people I don't know
what to tell you but I I wish we could
stop commenting on women's looks from
other women to when you asked me how old
I am for the the glass of wine just just
zip it I don't need your opinion about
how I look in fact not looking young too
young was helpful for the particular
thing I auditioned for I was I was
really excited that my crow's feet were
showing a little bit cuz I wasn't
supposed to look like some young thing
so listen her email wants a tip now of
course I'm reading this three months
late because this how we do and I seem
fun he says Jen I was wondering in the
spirit of the new year well how about in
the spirit of spring which began well
after this podcast will air I was
wondering in the spirit of the new year
and getting healthy would you consider
sharing your favorite Health's lush diet
tips I'm not asking in a cheesy eat less
exercise more way but specific to the
supplements you take and how you are so
in tune with your body and its needs
parenthesis reflux I admire so much how
you figured all that [ __ ] out I would
love your vice
advice on a basic starter kit well I
cannot see now I don't know how old this
person is but I know with the kids these
days they think it's like a
one-size-fits-all and that you ask a
question and you get the answer and
that's how everything looks and I'm in
tune with my body because at a certain
point you have no [ __ ] choice when
you are a woman of a certain age even
though I look good
amazing I am you know women are in touch
with their bodies because we have
periods and we have issues like Brett
lumps in our breasts or this and our
that and so I've been having issues with
all my lady parts since forever not
anything terrible but like a lump
removed in my breasts in my 20s so then
you start talking to a doctor about that
and they explained like levels of
hormones that you should or shouldn't
have her you know that my sister had
breast cancer at 40 and I'm a vegetarian
so it was explained to me that like soy
actually raises estrogen and when your
estrogen is raised like you're at risk
for breast cancer so it's like over life
you just pick up tips and I think women
are more in tune with our bodies because
we have to be because we have I think
more complex bodies now in terms of
health tips I don't know what's gonna
work for everybody it has to be about
for me when I'm doing anything that's
quote healthy I'm looking up this
fasting diet that I'm going to tell you
about it's not as bad as it seems is oh
I'm sorry
is it's not about thinking about like
how am I gonna live longer huh - right
so you can get hit by a bus and it's
easy to go off the rails from any kind
of like diet or health situation if
you're doing it for some kind of
perceived sense of longevity right it's
like who [ __ ] knows and it's too easy
to just go oh why am I doing this for
the future [ __ ] it I could die at any
second so I'm gonna have the cheese cake
or whatever so whatever I do is for me
because I tour all the time and I'm I'm
changing time zones all the time I'm in
airplanes a lot everything I eat affects
me like those salty food in the
airplanes bloats me then I have to put
on clothes to go on stage that's a
problem the clothes have to fit so my
life demands that I'm in tune with my
body every second I get on planes during
cold and flu season like
and then I have to do shows I cannot
lose my voice as you saw I had to cancel
a gig in Buffalo New York I lost money
it pissed everyone off I'm probably no
friend of the helium Club franchise I
had my voice been lost
I wouldn't been able to do the audition
I did it's like I can't I cannot get
sick because I cannot plan my downtime
so the reflux thing it took two years to
figure out my ear nose and throat
doctors didn't know they kept telling me
that the reason I would do that and have
that like phlegm come up like you just
heard earlier was that um I had
allergies I've never had allergies I got
tested for allergies so I mean I don't
know how to explain it you've been with
me all these years you've seen me slowly
figure out things and again it's always
like there's a consequence like if I
don't take care of my reflux then I burn
out my vocal cords it's literally acid
comes up and burns my vocal cords and
you aspirate in your sleep and you start
coughing and it feels like you're being
waterboarded so it's like I don't want
that so I have to follow the so it's
like do you have an too acidic of a diet
well then you want to buy a book about
having a less acidic diet do you want to
lose weight then I can't tell you how I
mean I don't like cardio I don't believe
in it I this all this whole destructing
craze of like those bike classes all my
friends that ride those crazy bikes and
the SoulCycle I swear to god they gain
weight easier than anyone I know because
it's like at a certain point your body
is not going to keep burning calories
because you're pushing it like that if
you just hiked for an hour your body
your metabolism changes for the day it
don't you don't have to do crazy
SoulCycle whatever [ __ ] like that you
just don't the thinnest I've ever been I
wasn't even doing cardio I was just
doing Pilates every day so I you know
and being vegan so it's like it's really
about what you eat so I don't know a
basic starter kit would be to not ask a
generic question of a podcaster because
I don't have your body I might not be
your gender I might not be your age we
might not have the same thing so you
have to get in touch with what you
and you have to understand the basics
refined sugar is like putting a
cancer-causing agent in your body it's
it stops your moon immune system from
working its [ __ ] with your metabolism
the worst things for you are sugar based
because that stores as fat you know it's
like just read just figure out what
makes you feel good I mean you know how
you feel after you eat like [ __ ] it's
cuz your body is a machine and food as
fuel and that was my point if you kind
of look at it that way like I want to
eat well not for weight loss or so that
I have some goal of living to 90 but I
want to feel good today and tomorrow
because I've [ __ ] to do it's like kind
of a self-respect thing when you get
down to it it all comes back down to do
I love myself do I respect myself do I
want to feel good while I'm doing the
things I need to do so that I can be
present and help others and be focused
and whatever well food has a big part of
that so and then within that if you are
coming from a place of self love and
self respect there's no notion of
cheating and only I had this and I
shouldn't know if it's like acid reflux
is is my thing like wine is not great
for it but wine is the only alcohol I
like and every once in a while I like to
have a glass of it so I do and I take
the proper like acidic medications right
after just to tamp that down can I drink
wine five times a day every day
no can I like get super drunk like I did
on drunk history no that's why I don't
do it anymore so one of my favorite
things though when I'm like don't have
time to work out or I'm running around
and I just want to make sure that I'm
not gaining anything is the the 8 hour
diet so you fast 16 hours a day and then
you eat during this 8 hour window and
they've said that that kind of stuff
intermittent fasting if you guys just
google intermittent int erm ITT anti
intermittent why do I feel like I'm
saying that wrong intermittent fasting
is a great way to lose weight because
the human body is designed for periods
of eating and then periods of fasting
and it does like
shift your metabolism a little bit so
I've never been someone who works very
well with that rule you're supposed to
eat every two three hours like snacks
I've never I'm not that hungry all the
time but when I am hungry I'm a I'm real
hungry so it's like they say like if you
stop eating after 6:00 let's say 12
hours and then is 6:00 a.m. so let's say
you go to bed at 10:00 you and you wake
up at 6:00 a.m.
you've already gone so if you can not
eat from 6:00 to 10:00 then you go to
bed then you wake up at 6:00 a.m. you
it's already been 12 hours you haven't
eaten and then at 10 a.m. you have your
first whatever the day so I mean I kind
of live that way a little bit especially
with the silent reflux stuff is you're
supposed to stop eating like three four
hours before you go to bed and I love to
go to bed early so that's kind of what I
do that keeps my I don't [ __ ] know
what it does but I mean I do healthy
things like I do Pilates
I sit in those infrared saunas if you
guys want to look that up they're not
admit in many places I mean it's like
New York LA I don't really know where
else they have them I do stuff like that
a lot of people like to have a TSP of
raw apple cider vinegar in the morning I
guess it's supposed to help your
metabolism it's not good for my voice so
I don't I'm as you know I haven't eaten
red meat since I was 13 or poultry so I
don't know that works for me this whole
myth about protein is absolutely
ridiculous you can get it from plants
nuts other things you don't need that
much protein and we get plenty this note
that the the four food groups you know
all that stuff and the dairy and the
meat like that's not designed by like
some angel that came down and said I
made your body and here's what we need
though that's that's the FDA that's like
the Food and Drug Administration that's
people trying to sell you [ __ ] do you
understand I'm saying that whole notion
of all those grains we need no it's
vegetables and lean protein and you
don't need lean protein for me I forget
one of my favorite episodes of one of my
favorite podcast 10% happier with Dan
Harris of ABC News
there's another guy whose name is
similar to Dan Harris but it's not him
he had someone on who's like a health
whatever and he was talking about this
notion of freaking of the protein being
kind of BS and I cannot find it and I
meant to write it down and keep that
episode forever and talk about it all
the time and then I didn't and then I
didn't but oh maybe I can find it maybe
I can find it maybe I'll tweet at him
and ask if he remembers and then we'll
talk about it in another episode remind
me to do that tweet uh I'm gonna write
myself a note tweet at and ask who the
protein guy was okay well that's fun you
just looked at me write a note to myself
is this this is really this podcast is a
waste of this beautiful studio I'll put
it to you that way Erin's laughing
because he knows it's true oh my god I
tried to watch the Ricky Gervais
stand-up special oh lo it that's a tough
one
I'm not gonna make fun of it it's
everyone has their own taste sure people
hate mine well I know they do I read
about all the time but there's just some
about that guy he's turning into David
Brent
like he's doing stuff that David Brent
would even be like I shouldn't do this
there's just something about this
obsession with these male white sis
misspoke comics talking about trans
people they are obsessed with this
notion of guys cutting their dicks off
which is not what being trans is even if
you do get surgery it's it's literally
like not the not your business and not
the point and it's it's almost like it's
their worst fear coming true like what
if I wake up one day and want to cut my
dick off and it's like I don't know
there's just something strange about it
to me and it seems like the way a little
kid wants to keep poking at something
because they want to play too and they
want to learn about it and it's like
then learn about it you're going about
it this really weird way no not that um
us non trans people can't talk about it
if we think like hey this is new to me
or this seems weird or whatever I mean
look we got to be able to talk about
things but it's it's dangerous when you
have a big audience and you're not
talking about it in a way that is
leaving any room for your own error and
millions of people are like laughing or
not maybe not millions that is taping
but thousands people are laughing and
you know people watching it are like
screaming at the TV going now that's not
what it's about for me so I don't know
it's like you needed to make a Caitlyn
Jenner joke really like and put it on
the TV years after all this really went
down anyway years after you know she
first revealed herself as Caitlyn and I
know it's just like what what is going
on in your life lately dude tell me
about you I don't want to hear your
thoughts on trans I really [ __ ] don't
unless it's I don't know unless you're
gonna have a trans person come out and
do a roast battle with you or something
look please don't do that neither I
don't want to see that anyway there's
just something about it that's like the
guy was never really a stand-up it he
gets on stage and does jokes and he
thinks he's being naughty teehee and it
reminds me of dudes at their open mics
and he's a big name and Netflix wants
him and I totally get it but there's
other comics real ones who have a great
new hour and know where to put it just
yet so it actually sounds like I'm
personally upset it's actually not about
me but I did try to watch the special I
don't care where it was if it was just
you know I don't know what on a network
that doesn't exist anymore
I would still be like I don't know
there's just something I mean all the
reviews of it have been scorchingly bad
vulture tore it apart
I think the a/v Club so yeah I just it's
disappointing because I'm I'm the
biggest fan of the English office I was
a early listener to his podcast I loved
extras
and I think that's where I heart waits
with him um I just I can't get into it
but that's okay I don't do like
everything everyone that I like or like
for certain things does right I'm at
thirty right is it time to talk about
talk space I think so I'm gonna talk
about talk space everybody this episode
is brought to you by our favorites at
talk space the online therapy company
that lets you message a licensed
therapist from anywhere anytime
can't imagine fitting another
appointment into your life I [ __ ]
can't
I actually cancelled my therapy this
week because of set appointments and the
pain in the ass about it is I have to
reschedule it and actually like go
somewhere now you know I mean I go
somewhere all the time when I'm therapy
but with talk space you don't have to
it's as easy as sending your therapist a
message no commutes no leaving the
office and no judgments to match with a
perfect therapist for a fraction of the
price of traditional therapy go to talk
space.com slash Jen that's one in and
Jen chieh and and use code Jen to get
forty five dollars off of your first
month and to show your support for this
show so all you need is a computer with
an internet connection or the talk space
mobile app so you can improve your
mental health even if you've had trouble
making time for it in the past and even
if you've been like I don't have enough
money for those big expensive sessions
well everything has just changed and you
don't have to be like oh my god I've got
this childhood trauma you can just you
know like that guy who asked me a
question about getting his life together
maybe what I said to him about you know
it really starts with self-respect maybe
he's like I don't know if I have any I
don't know if I have what it takes to
make changes you could talk to a
therapist about that they could help you
with your life any aspect you can go as
deep as you want talk space has over
2,000 licensed therapists they are
experienced in addressing life and all
of the challenges that we all face there
is nothing wrong with taking care of
your mental health
in fact I demand that you do I don't
want any listeners who aren't taking
care of their mental health
I want to everyone healthy up and hip
takk space.com slash Jen use code Jen to
get $45 off of your first month if
that's not a deal then I don't know what
you people want what do you people want
free therapy you're not gonna get it
except by listening to I sing fun but
I'm not a real therapist I'm just
someone entertains you so why not go and
get your brain going get your beachbody
brain for the summer all right
and we are also sponsored today by quip
I've been using my quip been travelling
with it it is a toothbrush in case
you're like what are you saying here's
what you're gonna do you're gonna go to
quip calm quu i p.com
slash fun and you're gonna read about it
on your own but here's the deal you
don't need a big expensive toothbrush to
get the oral care that you need you can
get the same refreshing clean with
something simpler that'll give you the
best brushing experience you've ever had
your dentist will also tell you you
don't have to pay hundreds for a
top-of-the-line electric toothbrush and
this qyp toothbrush is literally like if
Apple designed a toothbrush but way less
expensive it's an electric toothbrush
that packs premium vibration and timer
features into an ultra slim design so
it's cool I have a really cool gold one
and it's it is very slim and yeah when
you're brushing your teeth its vibrating
and then it stops and you know to move
on to the next quadrant it's very
awesome and it's a subscription service
so you get the toothpaste you get brush
head refills you can subscribe to
receive new brush heads on a dentist
recommended three month plan how many of
you think you know oh I think it's time
to throw away my toothbrush you've
probably been using it for 11 months
you have no I you have no concept of
time and you know it you need this you
need this so you can even subscribe to
receive new brush heads on a dentist
recommended three month plan for just
five dollars that includes free shipping
quip starts at just $25 so right now go
to get quick comm slash fun to get your
first refill pack free with a quip
electric toothbrush that is your first
refill pack for free at get quick calm
/font
et qu IP comm slash fun it was named as
one of Time Magazine's best inventions
of 2016 it won a 2016 GQ grooming award
and it's on oprah's 2017 new year's o
list do it
75% of you don't refresh your bristles
or visit the dentist on time
that's why you need quip it tastes fresh
it strengthens your teeth and it gives
your mouth perfect clean feeling don't
walk around there with bad bad breath
people don't do it don't do it to others
alright we're back we're back how long
have I been on here in Rome 38 38
minutes that's it yes Oh for [ __ ] sake I
also try to look for that podcast for
you could not find it but I did see that
you were on I was only 7 I was on 10%
happier with Dan Harris episode 77 about
a year ago yep um so yeah this I'm gonna
find it I'm gonna tweet him an axe and
then we'll have it next week but you
know what I'm gonna do a typical I seem
fun thing right now as I'm sitting here
because I forgot my phone
I don't have the Wi-Fi password yet for
this new studio I mean I'm sure you have
it but I'm not gonna ask you on air but
I'm gonna tweet from my phone oh I see
it right there the pink one all right
Dan Harris where is it Dan Harris Dan
Harris oh yeah here it is Dan random
question do you remember is this fun for
everyone
do you remember the guest you had on a
few months ago who passionately talked
about the myths of protein and needing
huge amounts and needing huge amounts of
meat trying to reel in trying to find
that episode of your podcast all right
let's see if Dan Harris writes me back
and he might be like why would I [ __ ]
know that when people are like what
podcast episode did you say 1 2 3 my cat
the [ __ ] what I know I'm not paying
attention um all right hopefully hold me
a little nicer and then I would be so
here's the article ax oh right so I'm
not connected so let me just get on the
Wi-Fi and I'm gonna read you this is it
800 is it studio okay I'm gonna read to
you this exciting thing
it'll be a TC guest Oh a TC guest oh
here we go okay never mind
guys have you ever heard of a podcast
more exciting than when someone checks
into a wait it's all three words all in
a row with a space in between oh this is
really an annoying thing hack-proof
that's for sure
but who cares if a Wi-Fi gets hacked
does that mean it does it matters oh it
does now when wi-fi's get hacked uh
couldn't do it when Wi-Fi is get hacked
does it mean that um they would have
access to all of our network Oh and so
they can like wreak they can see in here
and get into oh yeah oh I always thought
Wi-Fi being hacked this so dumb I am
meant people could just use your Wi-Fi
for free like stealing cable that's
literally the only thing I thought
stealing Wi-Fi was about that's what
you're you're Joe Blow hacker would do
yeah I'm I didn't know there was more
levels of hacking than my Joe Blow um
well that's good to know so I don't want
people to hock my Wi-Fi at home then
yeah I should probably change my
password ever
three months oh Jesus yeah well I will
all right well here's the deal I've been
reading this off my phone this came out
on March 14th NASA study astronauts DNA
is no longer identical to his identical
twin after a year in space Scott Kelly's
jeans are no longer identical I just
read that preliminaries results from
NASA's twin study found that 7% of
Kelly's jeans no longer matched those of
his twin mark now headlines are so
misleading they're no longer identical
so and well I guess it's me taking it I
go I'm in a hundred percent then you
know but 7% which I guess still means no
longer identical even if 1% of your
genetics is off it is not identical so
okay
I guess I should calm the [ __ ] down
preliminary rule is 7% of Kelly's jeans
no longer match those of his twin marks
Scott Kelly spent one year aboard the
International Space Station during the
study while his brother remained on
earth that's where I would remain by the
way I cannot go to space do not make me
he used to say that about Australia I'm
too afraid to fly there I know there's a
great comedy festival there
I'm never going it's just not gonna
happen and watch I will be in space I
bet I'll be there like I love it up here
because everything I'm afraid of ends up
being my favorite thing so seven percent
of Kelly jeans no longer match those of
his twin mark Scott Kelly spent one year
aboard the International Space Station
during the study while his brother
remained on earth I just read that while
in space researchers monitored Kelly's
metabolites cytokines and proteins to
learn how space travel affects
biological systems I bet it's a massive
jet lag when you know though most of
Kelly's biological changes returned to
baseline levels after returning to Earth
seven percent of his genes point to
possible long-term changes according to
the study nasa's preliminary findings
were validated this week according to
space.com that seems like a fake website
but i guess it's not the twins study has
benefited benefitted NASA by providing
the first application of genomics to
evaluate potential risks to the human
body in space
according to a release from the agency
Kelly's one-year mission was twice as
long as astronauts typical missions
aboard the International Space Station
but it is a stepping stone to an
eventual three-year mission to Mars no
way the agency said too long for me Mark
Kelly who is also a retired NASA
astronaut is the husband of former Rep
gabrielle Giffords Oh let's load the
comments let's see what the comment
section says just maybe it's not bad
this is the hill comm I don't know if
they get dumb people commenting but
somebody wrote now that is very
interesting all right it's not bad
comments somebody has said I said the
same thing this is a better story than
stormy Daniels I forget some real
intellects here what was even more
interesting to me this is another
comment was that they said in another
story that much of his DNA returned to
normal only two hours after he was back
on earth I had no idea it could change
so much so fast
this other person corrected him no no
they said his baseline readings returned
to normal his DNA didn't change his
expressed genes did which is amazing
because it may mean our biology may be
more compatible with living in space
than originally thought and then someone
else said well it could be devastating
to deep space travel if it took only one
year to alter 7% of his DNA forever what
would happen if he was on a 20-year trip
to Mars they would probably die before
they got there from this kind of damage
what have you had a nice 20 years in
Mars somebody else wrote we've been
living in space for tens of thousands of
years time too hard to tell the
difference anymore what well I mean
technically we are living in space yeah
exactly that's what he meant right yeah
of course that guy had to be weigh in
with his little like excuse me sir
excuse me I'm gonna be deep right now
then this guy wrote Scott Kelly is 1/16
is now 1/16 Cherokee okay and then
someone else an Elizabeth Warren slam
maybe weird and then somebody responded
to that Donny Trump has always been half
mystery meat and then someone else wrote
smoke actually Bill Maher found he is
half
Shemp he has pictures to prove it
somebody else would I believe it was an
orangutan yes
so eventually things devolve into
political fights yeah about Donald Trump
that that was kind of my oh and then
someone else wrote mr. Pocahontas
someone else read him in Liz Warren so
where would Kelly end up if he was
forced to march 116th of the way to
Oklahoma somebody else wrote can't any
of you people just stick to the story
why are a majority of the avatars on
this site oh okay
yeah so that's that's usually what
happens things devolve into madness now
last week I told you I'd be reading once
a week from this book The Little Book of
feminist saints and so we're gonna learn
about a new lady every week or maybe she
won't be new to you oh yeah you know
what Eleanor Roosevelt why not
she's our read for today we'll close on
this the matrons saint of commonsense
born 1884 in the United States her feast
day is October 11th quote Eleanor I
hardly know what's happened what's to
happen to you in a Rebecca Hall once
told her young daughter whose childhood
looks earned her the nickname granny
you're so plain that you really have
nothing to do except be good Eleanor
Roosevelt was good though perhaps not in
the way her mother had meant it she was
not just the longest-serving First Lady
of the United States but became the
first chair of the United Nations
Commission on Human Rights the year
after she went on to be declared that
Gallup polls most admired living woman
in 1948 in 1949 and 1952 then in 1952
and 1953 and so on uninterrupted through
1961 the streak might have continued had
she not died the following year great
point much like her husband Franklin
with his fireside chats Eleanor had a
particular way of establishing intimacy
with the public quote my day her
newspaper column appeared six days a
week for an astonishing 27 years she
wrote familiarly from her first entry on
New Year's Eve 1935 I wonder if anyone
else glories in cold and snow without an
open fire within
by oneself in one's own room exhibiting
shades of Virginia Woolf Eleanor's
column became a platform to for her
political opinions about race the war
women's rights education in November
1960 she wrote regarding the future of
the country whether you are a Republican
or a Democrat it seems to mean this
question of how we approach saving the
world and its people from themselves is
not a partisan question indeed until
next week have fun